زي شو رايك تاكل اوكرانيه استخفت به موسكو
فقلب الطاوله على الجيش الروسي فمن ذو
بدايه العمليات العسكريه الروسيه على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه شكلت كتائب راك تاج او
العاديين جزءا كبيرا من دفاعك يافا عن
اراضيها الكتائب التي تضم تطوعين مدنيين
وبعد تحقيقها مكاسب كبيره في العاصمه كاف
تتجه نحو اقليم خرسان لتحرير المنطقه التي
يمكن ان تشهد اكبر واشهر الصدام منذ بدايه
الحرب قوات جيش الراكتك كانت السلطات
الاوكرانيه قد بدات تدريبها قبل بدايه
الحرب حيث قدر عدد هؤلاء وقتها باثنى عشر
الف شخص واستمر تطوع المدنيين في القتال
بشكل اكبر بعد اندلاع الحرب حيث ساهموا في
تحقيق انتصارات كبيره في الشرقيه البلاد
حيث جاء تحرير بالكامل واجزاء اخرى من
الدباس حسب ما كشفت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
الامريكي
[موسيقى]